what is happening there reject nation we
are about to go watch the bullet train
trailer but before we go into any of
that thank you to the amazing sponsor i
mean it amazing
sponsor displayed for sponsoring this
video if you don't know diskplate makes
gorgeous art prints on durable metal
sheets that are so easy to display and
swap out there are over 1 million
designs in their store from original art
to some of our favorite ips like marvel
dc and star wars and you won't need any
power tools thanks to diskplate's magnet
based mounting system which takes all of
about 20 seconds to install weeds got a
couple of the star collection got the
spider-man and batman up on the wall up
here in the studio to uphold the brand
and i just pulled this one out of the
packaging i'm gonna be hanging this up
somewhere in the living room i'm gonna
let the misses decide where this one
goes so if you're as jealous of that
displayed as i am hit our special link
in the description box to save yourself
23 on your first one or two displays or
27 if you buy three or more support stem
supports the channel they'll even plant
a tree for each one you buy so really
you're supporting planet earth now let's
watch some youtube
[Music]
hi
there's a gun
this is the quiet car
god he's your small inside voice in his
son there's a gun
[Music]
wow
brian tyrande
love it
talk to me i am ready you are getting
the new and improved me
because if you put peace out in the
world you get peace back
absolutely getting what you do for a
living
take the gun every job i do somebody
dies i'm not that guy anymore
some conflicts require a gun
lots of guns
hey this is nice
okay what am i snatching and or grabbing
a briefcase you said you wanted simple
for your first job back it doesn't get
simpler
sure
[Music]
bad bunny
you stab me
there's nothing simple about this job
something else going on here
yeah i'm not the only one on this train
looking for this case
where's the briefcase i was saying
taylor johnson
it was just here
we are right on settlement i love the
castle
that's a [ __ ] deal
[Music]
oh no thank you you know what do you
have uh anything sparkling
that's the one thank you tomorrow
i'm sure you want to talk this out no
particularly
okay
there we go
if you're gonna do a movie called bullet
train there better be a moment where
they're hanging off of the bullet trains
the only thing you need there's just one
epic ass ensemble right there david
leech my man this is why that brad pitt
cameo happened in deadpool 2.
to produce this one specific movie i'll
do your movie if you let me show up in a
day yeah dude man we got brad pitt in
here we got aaron taylor johnson we got
hiroyuki sonata from mortal kombat and
freaking the wolverine which was like
the first movie that always comes to
mind for me when i think of a bullet
train the wolverine movie yeah yeah
you're pretty good
sonata you got freaking brian tyree
henry joey king is in here
he's a great actress fantastic actress
also being british here you got logan
lerman who looks like they show him die
in the trailer which was kind of a
surprise zozzy beats michael shannon the
guy from warrior andrew copeland andrew
kojie andrews
is in there is she i didn't see her did
you see her i think she's over the phone
yeah she's playing the role that lady
gaga was originally going to play oh
yeah this is john's most anticipated
movie that's right man everything about
this film i don't know everything that
happens in this movie yeah marie beetle
let's do this based on a book all right
and actually something i was surprised
to learn um someone who i was uh part of
the bridal party for recently andrea
abby knows i was looking at imdb this
morning like oh crap she's in this movie
so so you got that hey track
you got all the secrets hey i'm gonna go
ask her like tell me every detail that
happened in this film it was like
working with brad pitt yeah so it's like
five assassins aboard a train all
looking for this one briefcase while
they have to battle it out on a bullet
train yeah i don't know the novel
whatsoever other than that little brief
description what we're getting here is
awesome because this feels different for
david leech like it seems like he's been
going down like action comedy route way
more it's like to debut alongside chad
stachowski for the john wick movies with
the direction he's got with like fast
and furious like hobbs and shaw deadpool
too and now to see him pulling off this
movie right here it's like such a pure
action comedy and i actually love to see
it day and age with so much marvel and
dc it's nice to get an original ip you
know to see this exactly my boy exactly
five men
riding like a bullet train
yeah this looks fun man it's got like a
quentin tarantino guy richie type of
vibe more guy ritchie i'd say than
quentin tarantino yeah this excites me
because it does look like kind of a nice
blend of david leech isms like you have
a certain comedic edge but it looks
maybe a little more soaked in that neon
vibe that like an atomic blonde might
bring the perfect next step i feel like
certain point he's gonna have to start
stretching his legs and really
surprising us with a slow moving sea
drama yeah with no action whatsoever the
action is the dialogue and it's in black
and white
square aspect ratio just the exact
farthest from this as you can get now
this looks like a really fun time but
also like the action and just like the
the punch behind the camera is gonna be
so involved like i feel like we've
talked about the david lynch and shed
stahelski movies which are all lynched
by the way david lynch is bullet train
it's it's 6 30.
actually david leech they're close to
david leach but yeah like because you
know chad stahls has pretty much just
done john wick and david leach has gone
off and yeah done more and more you know
sort of heightened action comedies this
looks kind of like the right mid level
for him to get like you know some of
that john wick bone crunch back without
sacrificing the fun that we know he's
capable of and the style and the you
know visual flare he's able to bring
behind the camera well i like seeing
like a lot of the wacky characters here
like aaron taylor johnson just having
such a fun time i still feel like he's
such an underrated actor i think he's
truly a gem so to see him here i'm
excited to see him bounce off of brad
pitt it's pretty much just gonna be a
movie where you're watching the
legendary oscar-winning brad pitt have
fun bouncing off of a bunch of amazingly
talented actors as well so i think
that's part of the joy to behold here i
want to get a better taste of the action
because that's the part where david
leach can be kind of interesting to me
about sometimes it seems like he's
really getting down the comedy he did
atomic blonde right that was what he did
the action of tom guan was awesome then
with deadpool 2 while the action was
really cool and same thing with you know
hobbs and shaw weirdly i still felt like
it was missing some of like oh that
david leech flair where i feel like
we're getting a lot more of it here
though yeah you know the tangibility of
the fights that especially something
like atomic blonde brought that you
didn't get in a deadpool or in a hobson
shot yeah yeah i like seeing brad pitch
as having just aft after winning an
oscar doing a role where he just seems
like he's having so much fun where he's
yeah the coolest stunt man ever and
apparently in this he really wanted to
do as many of the stunts and fights as
he possibly could so you know again
jon's most anticipated movie right he's
doing the keon reeves
thing but i like the approach of like he
seems like he's really got a good grip
on the tone because it seems like this
is such a specific tone like a dude who
who is a professional but he also just
wants to be a normal guy yeah yeah i
like that style as opposed to just
normal guy who's caught up in a
situation way over his head yeah it's
charming he's got a certain optimism
i'll say the thumbnails and images they
released made this seem like it was
going to be some like hairy ass serious
movie yeah
like oh this is like less really funny
yeah it just looks brad pitt looking
dramatic yeah all right guys what did
you think about this trailer please
leave your thoughts down below subscribe
click that bell thank you to display for
helping us sponsor this video we will
catch you all soon
you